today I show Cumberbatch your long and
strong into the Doctor Strange trailer
on today's Batman I'm Batman
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith mark barnard we're looking at you
through the eye of agamotto [ __ ] cuz
it's time to talk strange this week man
plethora oh yeah good [ __ ] happened you
know Justin just went there what is a
cynic on this guy's CinemaCon CinemaCon
is going on at CinemaCon Warner Brothers
announced that the Batman standalone
movie is a real thing and happening with
been in it and been directing it and
stuff and so for like a good six hours
eight hours the press cycle was all
about that and you're like good for
Warner Bros good for DC yeah thing
they got some going on and like
subtraction is yelling that I think it's
on purpose dude like Marvel the moment
like there's a little joy over at Warner
Brothers Marvel's like release the new
trailer
steal all the goodwill it's crazy they
did like they released the poster for
Doctor Strange and then they released
the trailers two poses there's one which
is [ __ ] gorgeous I know it looks like
it's in Kevin's drawer and it's not even
it does look like I said gives joy
excellent [ __ ] pull and it's not even
like like oh yeah here's a [ __ ] poster
with some super ears on its Benedict
Cumberbatch's like one of the most
beloved [ __ ] human beings on the
planet so people are gonna pay attention
to it and if that wasn't enough then
they were like here's a [ __ ] trailer
I sort of like in now the DC Marvel
relationship like those the big dog and
the little dog and was warned about this
cartoon shut up kid you bother me yeah I
like my friend spike because he's so big
and strong yeah man it's like they won't
give him a minute dude they just like
theirs and it doesn't go the other way
if you've noticed this yeah like DC
doesn't go like let's open up the razors
or anything like that here's what we got
it's Marvel and it's kind of classic
Marvel like it echoes as money as much
as these movies echo stories that we
loved in our childhood this type of
behavior of poking and [ __ ] stealing
thunder and like
louder and prouder goes so far back to
the mark Mary Marvel marching Society
when they were like on opposite sides of
New York and they called them DC our
distinguished competition it's all
reminiscent of that which is like you
know it's it's not [ __ ] that hurts DC or
Warner Brothers one iota but it is a
real like [ __ ] nipple twist because
every time they get a little heat
they're like let's put it out with the
blanket of Doctor Strange hey you guys a
date for your thing here's daredevil
season two guess what's coming to know
that all [ __ ] oh really god damn it okay
do you think it's intentional it's kind
of intense there's no no accident no
giant corporations don't do things like
that by accidents nuts so then then that
means like somebody somewhere probably
kept by you or something like that like
sitting there going release the hounds
yeah just seriously sharks with lasers
on their heads it's an amusing side
story to the wonderful stories that they
keep reminisce but in any event they
they Marvel just stole the week yes and
this is week three of Batman V Superman
Marvel's like came out with first we're
gonna show the movie early to people
mm-hmm some people right at this table
will talk about uber yes I've seen and
I've seen the a the Civil War okay so
they had that going on they've released
the the posters for Doctor Strange then
the trailer for Doctor Strange now
they're releasing scenes as well of
Civil War online and this movie comes
out when March May 6th so like three
weeks from now
so still three weeks like this yeah it's
boy they have dominated the news cycle
yeah and a part of it is because they're
proud of the movie and like it is a it
is a thing to see when a studio is not
afraid to show people their movie
because like [ __ ] it come see it we
don't care don't spoil it but you saw
Civil War too jaded give them give them
a gimme solo cuz give them a
single-camera give them a your writer
seven word review seven word review
don't count your fingers
say the alphabet without singing this
song everything you ever wanted in a
movie holy [ __ ]
number one well done but number two
that's a high [ __ ] that's high praise
listen I it is it is I think the best
Marvel movie they've made oh my god
[ __ ] put that on a poster Christ
that's high person alright so we're
gonna do that's another episode yeah you
come back later for that yeah yeah you
know right now though we're gonna just
gonna get strange as we've been saying
for the last like ten [ __ ] minutes
released a Doctor Strange trailer as
well as the posters and boy oh boy it
was amazing to see I'm not gonna say
like this trailer changed my life like
the road one trailer
yeah was a religious experience but this
trailer was more sentimental experience
for me cuz I was like there's the
accident there's his there's him like
with his hands [ __ ] up jazz hands yes
yes cuz that anybody knows the story
Stephen strange brilliant young surgeon
arrogant as well if I remember dick yeah
something of a dick he gets into this
accident his hands are [ __ ] useless
so he can't do surgery more so
everything he thought he was is [ __ ]
gone and that's when the ancient one
finds him where he goes walking or
looking I think he goes on walkabout in
that way as you do as you do if you're
like a white rich guy in comic books
like you know what I need to do find
myself climb a mountain Asia or what a
rich white lady with no hair yeah as in
coldest winter till this one just
killing it dude and I guess like nobody
knew she was gonna be bald but I assumed
she would be yeah I mean although it
still is she could not be bald I still
look just as alien and weird yeah she oh
she's such a good actress and she does
like she could pull off what do they
call that gender-neutral androgyny
androgyny yes oh we think I heard heard
Gabriel I think she plays Constantine
Hey so that technically makes her one
who walks between two worlds indeed
because she was a DC phloem technically
and now she's in a Marvel film yes is
that we got to keep a separate list of
those who walk between two years like
there's only so far like that I could
take out about like ten maybe less I'm
gonna say five probably I mean Chris
Evans I think is the king of doing that
excellent no because he walks in the
same world well he was in Marvel
characters but he was also Scott Pilgrim
Oh Oh points as Hardwick would say
points good [ __ ] blow that does make
him - he's got to world I think of the
two worlds as Marvel DC but technically
you're right man he came from that's an
OD book that's an only book so Andy book
but I wouldn't call him the king you
know Reynolds Reynolds may be the King
because he walked between a flat-out DC
property one of the big ones Green Green
Lantern and then now is further
ensconced as dip and was also in our APB
which was a dark horse book oh my god
[ __ ] I never want to be on a game show
you know everything if there's a nerd
game show their rewards dumbass arcane
trivia Vande come at me bro there's got
to be it we should create it did you rig
this let's look it looks look at who
else much you want shoes to wet all
spell chihuahua till age you should tell
Ejiofor Chewie which is the most
adorable thing ever in real life yeah
the [ __ ] out yeah so all his buddies
called showing Shoei there is look at
that [ __ ] guy that's really [ __ ]
cute I didn't know that man that makes
it easy on people too right Chewie and
also fun just use your friend do a
birthday party so I'm sure she was a
good guy Julie will [ __ ] shoot
somebody who kills it his friend that's
what Chewie is now he's playing Baron
more is he more do more do who is not a
good guy in the comics correct yeah I
think it was he was they were training
together and Maki will tell us these
things Matt they were both disciples and
our show producer is a massive massive
doctor stress he went he went you tell
him he'll took come on in here just
coming up set him like still up to the
mountain telling your story tell me a
jimmy kimmel story
I went to Jimmy Kimmel just to see the
trailer get out you know it was gonna be
playing stay on him the whole time yeah
you know there's good single single yeah
no III I went to the high marks let me
get out of here yeah I went to Jimmy
Kimmel just to see the trailer because I
was I mean they announced it last week
they announced a maybe even a couple
weeks ago so you were there in the room
yeah and who presented it Jimmy Kimmel
he was supposed to be on it but then he
couldn't make it last minute so they had
like a video of him and like they had a
big screen of him like massive and he
like talked to Jimmy I think it was
probably a recording but like he
announced it Jimmy Kimmel made some
jokes about him being a magician and
then they showed the trailer and I
wanted to leave because I was having no
hockey back tears really yeah come on
that's from a true fan yeah now what is
the backstory they trained together so
the story is that dr. strange you know
looking for to heal his hands discovers
the ancient one and when he gets into
the Ancient Ones temple see some things
that he doesn't look like understand but
he also still doesn't believe in it so
he's like no screw you guys this isn't
real magic but then he Baron Mordo is
he's kind of a student but he's more
like like a teacher in the Ancient Ones
school hmm and all like already a very
powerful sorcerer in his own right and
he believes that he's next in line to be
the ancient one he knows the ancient one
is on his way out and Doctor Strange
comes across him I want to say I don't
think he's talking to door mama but he's
summoning like some really ancient awful
magic to kill the ancient one Doctor
Strange discovers it Baron Mordo hexes
him with like a lock that only Baron
Mordo can see on his mouth and Doctor
Strange like that's the first experience
Doctor Strange really has with magic is
now I can't talk and I don't know why my
mouth has been like locked by an astral
was like lock and I can't talk ancient
one sees through the magic heals him it
knows what Baron Mordo is up to and
kicks him out that's strange tells one
11 and 1/2 all they think how closely
they go home oh there they're not gonna
do that nest like I think there were no
friends I think here's here's my theory
they're gonna be friends in the movie
then the ancient one is going to be on
on her way out and dr. strange will end
up be becoming the sorcerer supreme and
that will be the split between the two
of them I think it's gonna be like an
actual really emotional like so it's
like Thor when Loki and Thor are like
best buddies and there were the princes
of Asgard and then Loki feels you should
have two throne and doesn't get it and
then that the sort of the love of the
Father being split amongst the sons yeah
is what fractures that relationship yeah
so I play with similar themes in these
movies later yeah and there's like a bit
of like just the same way there was a
bit of Iron Man 2 Ant Man there seems to
be a bit of Iron Man to this as much as
a hubris of like wealth and privilege
being and now I'm going to reinvent
myself I mean on origin stories I call
them but like very close to the mold
that they've made themselves I think it
looks pretty sweet yeah so I think at
the end of that movie he'll he will
split off and then I think I think the
sequel will be something like the
Eternity thug or something like that
that's one of the bigger graphic novel
stories who do you think Mads Mikkelsen
is playing oh I've got two theories
prepared no I I think I think he's one
of two P I think he's either a guy named
dr. Charles Benton who was an associate
of dr. Strange's at the hospital when he
was a doctor and he was actually a very
charitable guy he ran a charity he went
to dr. strange for money was like hey
man donate to my charity and dr.
strangers like you can go [ __ ] yourself
this is my money get the hell out and
then they both discovered the occult on
their own at separate times in he become
he goes on to become a priest of the
sons of satanic named Asmodeus okay you
know what dr. strange it has his mask
that's from Asmodeus okay so Asmodeus
casts him into I think the Dark
Dimension or the dream dimension and
then takes over dr. Strange's body and
dr. strange can't leave the dimension
unless he like takes on another likeness
so he basically erases his face because
dr. Charles Benton or Asmodeus has
already stolen it okay so long story
short we think that's Asmodeus or this
is Khalu the Kalu is a wizard so there
was a Dumbledore and then there was um
who was this his friend who like had the
death stick remember those two guys like
it was like the backstory so basically
the ancient one has that same story with
this guy named Kalu the ancient one I
believe is his original name was yeah
like five six hundred years ago he and
this guy kallu were best friends
kallu gets corrupted by a book called
the dark hold which is like the most
evil book and the world and he goes on
to like enslave an entire like town
until the Angel one kicks him out so I
think if someone of the two of those
like high school D&D flashback I think
it's one of the two of them because not
Dormammu you don't think much do I move
I don't think is Dormammu but I do think
it's possible that either one of them
are summoning him because that's what
happens in the Eternity so I go to shot
throwing up the horns for the summoning
of Dormammu because I they've got
they've got to introduce him in this
movie for the sequel because you we know
there's gonna be a sequel so I feel like
they've gotta introduce him in this
movie I think
Asmodeus makes sense to me because
instead of like being the sons of
satanís they could be like the sons of
Dormammu and he's summoning Dormammu
into himself that's why Baron Mordo does
in the Eternity saga so they could steal
that exact same thing give dr. Charles
Benton that power so now explain to me
as a somewhat Doctor Strange layman I'm
like Doctor Strange layman here
what does strange have to do at some
point with Infinity stones because if
you're introducing Doctor Strange this
movie now
he's got to play a role in the infinity
war no soul jam or spiritual the two
gems that are left are the soul gem and
the time you had the [ __ ] soul gem
that's what I think but all the rumors
are saying time Jim because apparently
this movie has an element of time
trouble in it really yeah
they done that in the Marvel Universe
yet devil no no I don't think so I mean
they've dealt like like with flashbacks
and stuff like that but I that's the
rumor I don't know if it's true or not
but like there's been a rumor that the
time stone will have will have something
to do with that and some of them would
have if they had the time stone then who
has the dynamics no more movies right
yeah well I mean there's there's Thor
there's you know like yeah and black
peppers apparently got a big role for
the Infinity Ward like a big role in
setting up the movies did he have a big
role in civil war as well we'll talk
about but in Infinity Gauntlet Doctor
Strange played a big role in like
getting all of the heroes to the side of
the universe where Thanos was and he
kind of kept that he kind of kept Thanos
from approaching the earth with his
magics okay
so he might be they could I mean [ __ ]
pole cumber [ __ ] into a green screen
and be like just do this [ __ ] for five
minutes we'll [ __ ] around with did you
see the main that someone had of him
like hops playing hopscotch and like
dancing and stuff did you see the
pictures we were away when the pictures
went up there of him [ __ ] Jim and
Lee's universe shopping from in the
comics there was Jimmy Emily's universe
whatever was yeah and bought Doctor
Strange books about the Oh as [ __ ]
Doctor Strange we just hop straight by
it by the way if you're looking for a
book to read the oath is a great place
to start it's a really uh yeah for the
most part it's like a 2008-2009 book
where doctors it starts off with Doctor
Strange being shot and then having to
operate on himself astral form he goes
to the night nurse then he has to save
long turns out long has I think brain
cancer or something like that it's it's
a really solid so do we think that
Rachel McAdams is playing the night
nurse I think she's playing one of the
three I know there's three of them and
Claire till there's one
double yeah Netflix show and then
there's two more I think one of them is
actually named Linda ovens I think she
might be that one I can't remember the
from Dallas yeah yeah there were three
of them that was Stanley like women want
to read comics now let's give them
nurses what else do we see in that
trailer
fill in anybody well I mean it's very
thanks man Frank for pretending to be me
for a second give me a goddamn single
single hi guys who are you what did you
like about it what do you see that what
you were like I mean it's sort of like
it's a teaser it's very much a teaser
and they're not giving you any story
they're not giving you any like when I
unzip in our pants just yet they gave me
enough story as much as like this boy
got hurt now he's magic right like you
give save thousands of people make and
save the world I get that look at that
trailer uninitiated could look at that
trailer and be like that boy lived
now he's magic that's the boy that lived
as a Harry Potter be some way to find
them I'm pretty sure this is a part of
me but it's also very inception it's
very like the visuals folding on itself
even they're like the boom music at the
end of the trailer like it's very much
if you like Christopher Nolan that what
it is that shot is a shot of the world
folding you know so yeah and I think
there's a little baby doctor strange
falling between them really yeah like
right there Onis and ask the director is
scott derrickson yeah he was on an
episode of smoothie makers a couple
years ago
lovely [ __ ] dude didn't do like
sinister or the conjuring or whether he
did sinister and he also did Exorcism of
Emily Rose was his breakout and then he
did that it was at War of the Worlds
with Keanu Reeves not War of the Worlds
The Day the Earth Stood Still so he's
made like a big movie before then he
went and did sinister it was small and I
think the sequel and they both made
money and yeah but they I think when I
was talking to him I think he they were
this I don't even know if this was in
the offing but he was a really [ __ ]
small
guy good dude man all peer film like
loves film and [ __ ] this looks like yeah
then he made him does not say he's made
some fine films great-looking movies it
way better than [ __ ] I make but this
looks like a quantum leap forward yeah
and it looks like sure this is yes very
assured very much like I'm [ __ ] here
to play man like the same way that
what's this home boy did guardians of
the galaxy know James Gunn yeah like
James Gunn stuff was always [ __ ]
watch ball we spawn always like uniquely
is but when you saw Gardens the galaxy
like Jesus Christ this got pulled out
every [ __ ] stop in every trick like
he's showing off what he could [ __ ]
doing a big bad way same thing here with
Derek's and menos I was happy to see
that this I was excited about this movie
to begin with but I got very excited
about each other particularly last 10
seconds where he walks up the stairs and
he's [ __ ] got the cave you see the
window should so good Marvel magic there
it is look at that look at that dude
that's the money shot Patang and you
know that's it's they better not hold
that till the end of the movie dr.
strange but I get that kick now I've
seen him running in like because they're
shooting in New York and yes or wherever
they're shooting like they're out in
public so people are taking pictures of
crazy
I saw shot him and Chewie running in the
street wearing their capes yeah which
looks weird when it's not in a movie was
just until you're like that's strange
damn yeah like huh she's a guys trying
to get a cab get in a car buddy
uber magic cabs this this this is Marvel
doing magic yeah
and it's new this is a space three or
four well this is three this will be
three magic yeah we get magic we get to
cello we get Captain Marvel or she four
she's three yeah phase four they haven't
talked about that's after the infinity
war stuff okay so we're in phase three
damn exciting stuff damned exciting
stuff well there it is man Yes Doctor
Strange trailer kids Ranger now go peep
it off you haven't seen him come on well
you haven't
come on you guys don't be silly that's
all the time we got for this episode I
was almost gonna say weekend episode
this episode whoo comebacks next episode
and we're gonna talk about the Suicide
Squad trailer hitch I liked it I liked
defenestration happening or these are
guts filling up no no it's the other
side there it is come back next episode
yeah I've been Kevin Smith and Mark
Barnard come see us here in the fat cave
again next time same fat time saying fat
chance markets.com award
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder